[Music]
cambodia's King arrives for the opening
of the new parliament in the capital
Plum pen
just behind him Hun Sen prime minister
since 1985.
despite International condemnation that
the election in July was neither free
nor fair the king maintained he had
faith in his new government
I strongly believe that the new mandate
government will receive the confidence
from the Parliament and will fulfill
duties in accordance with the policy to
continue to push for economic growth and
lift the livelihood of people
but this Parliament will see a shift in
power not from one party to another but
from father to son the first order of
business is a vote of confidence in the
new prime minister
and with 120 of 125 seats in the hands
of the Cambodian People's Party the CPP
the result is in no doubt
hunman has been groomed for the top job
for several years
he took a noticeably high profile role
in campaigning during the last election
race although he remained quiet about
his plans for the new role
and a fluent English speaker hunman may
look more presentable than his father
who grew up as a fighter in the jungles
of Cambodia in Vietnam but those
expecting a change in policy are likely
to be disappointed
his way of thinking is not different
from his fathers but he has more
capabilities than his father he is more
presentable on the international stage
and he is seen as untarnished
that transition has already started just
last week hunman was presented to
China's foreign minister Wang Yi when he
visited Phnom Penh the smile suggests
that cambodia's powerful allies expect
friendly relations to continue like
father like son Tony Chang Al Jazeera
foreign